did you know that most men think of the
Roman Empire every single day
this fact has gone viral as a meme
because a woman asked her husband you
seen The Tick Tock where the woman says
did you know that most men think of the
Roman Empire daily and she asked her
husband and he says yes I do now I know
what you're thinking you're thinking
there is no way that my spouse thinks
about the Roman Empire daily
I asked my husband last night in jest
and do you know what this man said he
said well in some capacity probably
every day why
so when I saw the meme go around
I thought to myself because I wasn't
conscious of the fact that I think of
the Roman Empire every day but I do the
minute I saw it I said oh yeah I guess I
do
what do do women not think of the Roman
Empire every day and then I was sitting
at home in sweet little Elisa turned to
me she goes mag she saw the meme she was
Mac
do you
do you really think of the Roman Empire
every day I thought girl I you live with
me I basically talk about the Roman
Empire every day are you kidding why is
that so why why do men think of the
Roman Empire every day
it's to me it seems pretty obvious
this is the Roman Empire was the last
time that we had a Unity of
all of Western Civilization a a perfect
Unity of it you had a total political
Unity of all the lands and the peoples
you had a theological Unity after the
Edict of Milan after after uh
Catholicism then becomes the official
religion of the Roman Empire you have a
Unity of religion
you have a Unity of politics you have a
Unity of land you have a Unity of
everything and then with the fall of
Rome which is the main historical event
that people compare anything to
then you see this breakup that you're
always trying to get back there was then
a uh a bit of a Resurgence with the Holy
Roman Empire though I Contin I consider
that to be sort of an extension of the
Roman Empire
and so I think that I think that counts
if I think about the habsburgs or
something I think I I think that
qualifies as thinking about the Roman
Empire every day but but Dante was
writing about this in the Middle Ages
how there was just this yearning in the
western mind to return to the Roman
Empire because
of that Unity that we were all seeking
we're all just so frag and now we're so
extraordinarily fragmented that's why
that's why people make these comparisons
to the fall of Rome all the time
because they know that that was a bad
thing but the the other
side of the the men think about Rome
every day story at my friend Spencer
Clavin pointed this out was so
delightful about it is it's the first
time in a while we've seen one sex
stumble upon a fact about the opposite
sex
and get a kick out of it
so often today when one sex finds out
something about the other sex or comes
to some observation about them it's it's
an observation made in disgust or
revulsion this is obviously true of the
feminists when they discover anything
masculine they call it toxic and it's
true even of the red pill bro men who
just don't like women that much and
attack women all the time but this is a
good example
of women discovering something that they
previously didn't know about men and
thinking huh that's kind of cute I don't
know that's sort of delightful it's kind
of which is of course how it's supposed
to be because men and women are
different no matter what our cultural
Elites tell us today and that difference
is not a cause of pain and revulsion and
uh political problem
as our Elites tell us today it's
actually a cause of delight in one of
the Great
one of the great aspects of Life as a
human being
right now go to expressvpn.com Michael
Knowles show let me ask you something
when you use the bathroom do you always
close the door behind you right you
probably don't think you leave it open
you don't want random passersby looking
in on you so why would you let people
look in on you when you go online using
the internet without expressvpn is like
going to the bathroom and not closing
the door gross I can say with full
confidence that expressvpn is the best
VPN on the market here's why number one
expressvpn does not log your online
activity they've developed a trusted
server technology that makes it
impossible for their servers to store
any data at all to speed expressvpn does
not slow down your user experience you
can even stream HD videos with zero
buffering three expressvpn is incredibly
easy to use just fire up the app and tap
one button to connect if you are like me
and you believe your online activity is
your business use my link expressvpn.com
Michael Knowles show today and get three
months free in a one-year package that
is exp r ESS vpn.com Michael Knowles
show expressvpn.com
michaelenoll's show Susanna Gibson I've
now said initially I didn't even want to
say This Woman's name
on the show when the story came out
she's the Virginia House delegate
candidate who uh
produced a lot of porn of herself to
make money
um now I mean the story is pretty in the
mainstream I don't think uh I don't
think the cause of chivalry is served
all that much by not naming her uh
Susanna
uh
was a porn performer until very recently
and uh did these things with her husband
and made money off of it and off of
these poor desperate guys and now she's
running for Virginia House delegates
well she she may have violated the
Commonwealth's prostitution laws
Virginia law says to quote any person
who for money or its equivalent engages
in sexual intercourse or other sexual
acts with another person quote is guilty
of prostitution which is punishable as a
Class one misdemeanor a former
prosecutor Sean Klein and a defense
attorney in Virginia Beach
said it's his view that it is a
chargeable offense
the statute is very clear he says to the
Daily wire you cannot for money or its
equivalent perform sex acts it doesn't
matter who's paying for the ACT if it's
an observer or the recipient you can't
receive money okay so This Woman's in
hot water understandably I almost feel
bad for her because her culture is so
normalized porn that she probably never
thought that she was violating the law
but still a very bad thing
my question on this has nothing to do
with the Virginia delegate race has
nothing to do with Susanna
how is porn legal
how is porn period legal
it's apparently not legal in Virginia
how's it legal anywhere
prostitution is illegal most places
so if prostitution is illegal if it's
illegal to take money for sex acts
because it degrades the human person
reduces the human being to nothing but a
mere object a sack of meat for sensual
pleasure
and so because that is degrading to
everyone and degrading for society and
in flames lusts and vices we've just had
a law throughout the country that that
sort of thing is not legal
how is that all illegal but if you put a
camera in the room it's legal
doesn't make a lot of sense how is it
illegal to sell your body for sex to one
person but it's legal to sell your body
for sex to 10 million people doesn't
make a lot of sense
in recent years some extreme radical
liberals and Libertarians have argued
that porn is protected as free speech
that has never been true anywhere that
has never been true in any state that is
not that has nothing to do with the
traditional conception of free speech or
the First Amendment or any of those
things as even most Libertarians will
admit to you
appeals to the prurian interest
obscenity are not protected speech
so why don't we use this kind of thing
why don't we use the case of Miss
Susanna in the house delegate race in
Virginia as what the libs call a
teachable moment
and use the opportunity
to rather than just I mean focus on the
woman get her out of the race do
whatever but
maybe we use that
to our advantage to keep pressing
forward on an issue on which I think we
will win boy what a great clip that was
now make sure that you subscribe ring
the bell make sure you get all the
updates for the Michael Knowles Show
YouTube channel see you next time